what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering the last Annihilation so
let's just get right into it right this
is an amazing story and I'm curious to
see how some of you guys handle it so
the thing about this is this initially
picks up on what's basically thrown
world two which is what used to be holla
but is actually home of the scroll and
Cree Imperium now for those of you guys
who don't know what's really going on
here one of the things that Marvel did
in recent years is they actually unified
the scroll and the cree races and those
are actually led by hokling who is one
part scroll but of course he's also with
Wiccan which is just kind of their thing
right they're couple ruling empires
together how nice would it be to be able
to just rule a combined Empire and just
kind of do your thing but the thing
about this is that these two groups
operating in unison this will actually
be a major focal point in terms of why
all this is happening once we get
towards the end but what ends up
happening is that with the create and
scroll imperiums basically unified
creating just one gigantic massive
Empire that the world is ultimately
attacked by the Mindless ones now here's
the thing the Mindless ones have been
around in Marvel Comics for a really
long time they're kind of like the
harbingers of dormammu right like a
Mindless one appearing or an army of the
Mindless ones appearing is very similar
to like the Silver Surfer showing up to
your world Galactus isn't far behind in
this case dormammu is not far behind
because dormammu rules the dark
dimension which is where the Mindless
ones reside the other part of this is
that the Mindless ones have been
depicted inconsistently over the years
in Marvel Comics they've been depicted
as being incredibly capable and Powerful
going toe-to-toe with like Thor and the
Hulk and stuff like that and then
they've been shown as relatively easy to
defeat a lot of times it really just
depends on who's writing the story in
this particular instance to really
provide gravitas and to show us how dire
and how dangerous they are they're
basically imbued with the power of
dormammu so when they emerge they're not
easily destroyed the bigger thing about
this though is that the Mindless ones
are an infinite Army so sure you might
destroy the ones who show up here more
will simply just follow right it's kind
of a war of attrition is really what's
going on now the other part of this is
that Wiccan for some of you all who ever
read like Children's Crusade or anything
like that Wiccan is the son of the
Scarlet Witch he is destined to become
exceedingly powerful right like to
become the new demiurge and basically be
a being of Godlike power he hasn't
really reached that point yet he is
incredibly capable I would argue he's
not as powerful as the Scarlet Witch was
during House of M but he certainly
Rivals the power of Stephen Strange
before Doctor Strange died the thing
about this though is that a being as
powerful as dormammu basically imbuing
the Mindless ones with his own abilities
that's a huge thing because those guys
who don't know where dormammu resides in
terms of the cosmic hierarchy he's more
powerful than Mephisto which is no small
thing so again it's pretty massive the
other part of this is that while this
attack takes place you ultimately have
dormammu who appears before the
Guardians of the Galaxy using the body
or kind of the the planetary form of ego
The Living Planet now it's basically ego
possessed by dormammu there's a reason
why this happened and again this is one
of those little Mysteries that we'll
find out later on but a portal opens and
that leads to all these different forms
of of the Mindless ones kind of like
these headless beasts or bodyless beasts
that are showing up to attack the
Guardians now when this takes place what
we end up doing here is we actually
switch over to arako also known as Mars
now for those of you guys again who are
just joining us here one of the things
that had happened during Jonathan
Hickman's X-Men run is that there was a
subsect of the mutant population which
it actually hailed from a different
dimension they had been locked away
there and there's a whole great big huge
thing but basically there were mutants
that existed out there in the Marvel
universe that we didn't know about once
they entered into the main Marvel
Universe they took up residence on Mars
and they renamed it to a Rocco as it
stands right now storm rules over them
so she's kind of like their queen or
leader if you want to call it that but
this basically leads to Peter Quill and
and Richard Ryder here at this Place
talking about everything because you had
the Hellfire Gala and you have a whole
bunch of things going on but they're
basically here kind of asking the
question and talking about something
called mysterium now mysterium is a new
material that was introduced into Marvel
Comics and it is a pretty significant
material it's not anything insane but
the reality here and there's kind of
going to be a kind of explanation that
Dr Doom offers later on down the line
but we can go ahead and cover it here
mysterium is basically a substance that
is formed within the white hot room and
then is accessed by the mutant
population themselves the white hot room
is basically where the Phoenix resides
right the full power of the Phoenix
Force it's one of those places that just
kind of exists out there within the
Marvel Universe the reason why that
matters is because when it comes to
mysterium in the white hot room having a
material that literally is channeled
from what is in effect the Wellspring of
all creation is a pretty significant
thing but the funny thing about this is
that despite all of his properties and
his capabilities which we'll talk about
once we get to the conversation between
Doctor Doom and storm Mr ethereum is not
as durable as adamantium it's one of the
things that Marvel's always maintained
no matter what material you see in the
Marvel Universe nothing will ever be as
durable or as strong as true adamantium
which is what's bonded to Wolverine's
skeletons so just kind of away from all
to maintain that whole situation now in
the midst of all this they basically
have moon dragon who's a telepath that
exists out there in Marvel Comics that's
part of the Guardians of the Galaxy
communicating with Peter Quill and
Richard Ryder and telling them hey so
like the Mindless ones are basically
attacking the Guardians of the Galaxy
and uh dormamus invading the universe so
we need you guys to show up do something
uh we need some help
and so what it actually does is it leads
to Richard Ryder taking off and then
instructing Peter Quill to contact
Abigail brand and the sword station now
for those of you guys again who are
unfamiliar with this the sword station
and really Abigail brand were introduced
back during Joss whedon's astonishing
X-Men run in 2004. Abigail bran had to
head she had kind of LED sword for a
long time when Marvel went into uh the
alpha flight protocol and basically had
Carol Danvers Captain Marvel leading the
alpha flight protocol Abigail Bram was
effectively ousted she's more recently
returned again one of those instances
when Comics change but always go back to
the status quo but the thing about
Abigail brand is she doesn't really have
any significant Powers she's a person
that can speak any language from any
race that exists out there in the
universe but sword stands for the
sentient World observation and response
department where Shield monitors Earth
sword monitors space and so having sword
operate is kind of an extended arm of
the mutant population because Abigail
brand herself is a mutant it allows
mutants to kind of keep an eye on
everything going on out there in the uni
Universe should there be some kind of
threat to them or anything else but what
this would mean is by contacting Abigail
brand it could also invoke the
involvement of the mutant population and
so where you do have a fight going on
between the Guardians of the Galaxy and
the Mindless ones and Gamora and Rocket
Raccoon basically lose the protection of
their ship and they're kind of stranded
out there in space in the same way Peter
Quill was in the first Guardians of the
Galaxy film Richard Ryder Nova arrives
just in time to save them and at that
point we basically switch over to a
moment when you have hulkling that
basically calls for the release of
Captain Glory now here's the thing about
this right Catherine Glory he's a
character that's relatively new this guy
is awesome what's really kind of
interesting about this though to be
quite Frank with you he's very similar
to the way Ron and the accuser used to
be in Marvel Comics so Captain Glory was
introduced to us really in like 2018 as
part of the more recent Avengers run but
the idea behind this is there was a
contest that took place between the
Grand Master one of the Elders of the
universe and a guy by the name of the
Challenger what ended up happening is
that the Grand Master form what was
called the lethal Legion where basically
he started snatching these different
individuals from points in which they
were about to die and that's what was
going on with Captain Glory he was
literally involved in a fight he was
about to be destroyed he was snatched up
by the Grand Master brought onto his
team and then of course the contest in
suit and so as part of this contest in
the case of Grandmaster if he lost his
team would go right back to the moment
when they were supposed to die and
ultimately they were just simply perish
now because games with a grand master
are never as simple as they seem
ultimately the story came to an end but
Captain glory and those guys ended up
continuing on it was a way for Marvel to
introduce him into the universe and then
sideline him until they could bring him
back at a future point in time this
story being that instance Captain
Glory's dedication to really the cree
race is second to none this guy is a
he's a Believer right like this guy
follows the rules and and the the status
of the cree to a t he's very much like
Ron and the accuser was way back in the
day and so with him being released he's
a very formidable person to have on
their side because of his capabilities
in leading the cree Armada because of
his intelligence when it comes to
military campaigns he's the guy you want
on your side he's like General
Longstreet in the history of the
American Military campaigns just one of
the greatest commanders to ever live and
so what this does is it leads to him
kind of unifying the forces under
hulkling the problem is that as that
happens more Mindless ones show up and
that's the issue that they're running
into that when it comes to hulkling and
it comes to the forces of the cree race
facing off against these different
mindless ones every time they destroy
them there's a brief lull in combat and
then more portals open and they come
right back out again again it's a battle
of attrition and it's wearing your enemy
down and so at this point we switch over
to Doctor Doom meeting with storm now
this is not a meeting that you see very
often and it's actually really cool to
see them interact one of the reasons why
this never really took place is because
storm was never a person who was in a
position that in if we're being truthful
that Dr Doom respected the reality here
is that Dr Doom only expects people who
have a certain level of rank when it
comes to ruling anything right so like
ruling a nation or something like that
so comparable to his sort of authority a
person who has a great deal of vigor
that just has gumption or a person who
is equally powerful right it's one of
those things or equally intelligent
Doctor Doom is very very specific about
who he chooses to respect and rightfully
so right I mean Dr Doom's one of those
guys where he can just do that right you
know where it's just like hey uh I don't
know you but I don't respect you and
it's just kind of like I mean okay you
know it's interesting you know and you
just kind of walk away only a fool is
just like No Doctor Doom we're all equal
here and you're really hurting my
feelings right you know what Dr Doom is
going to say you tell Dr Doom that he's
hurt that he's hurting your feelings you
know what he's going to say he's gonna
say Allah hurt a lot more than that if
you don't get out of here that's what Dr
Doom is going to tell you right it's
just one of those things you don't go to
Doctor Doom complaining about your
feelings right otherwise you end up
being held in the prison cell and
Liberia for the rest of your life and No
One's Gonna care enough to come looking
for you so the thing about this is that
when it comes to the conversation
between the two the main focus of this
is really mysterium it's Doctor Doom
trying to understand what the mutant
population is doing with it now there is
all the decorum there's all the proper
conversation and talk and Doctor Doom
like yes of course I respect you as a
leader storm storm sees right through it
right I mean she's she's not a fool and
it's one of the great things about storm
as a character ever since her
introduction into Marvel Comics she
exploded onto the scene and she's been
hugely popular among X-Men fans ever
since I love storm I've always been a
fan of storm she's just a great
character but she sees right through all
the decorum and all the talk and all
that Glitz and glamor and all that kind
of stuff storm is very much a
no-nonsense woman which is why I am so
excited to see her in the MCU and so
that's when Dr Doom basically drops all
pretense and he's like I want to know
what you guys are going to be doing with
mysterium now initially storming them
didn't know that Doctor Doom even knew
about mysterium in the first place not
only that he knows where they get it
from he knows that it like they tap into
the power of the white hot room now the
response of Dr Doom is this is no small
thing what you're doing here is no small
thing you're literally tapping into a
source of power and creation on a
universal level this is like you just
goofing off with the Infinity Stones
right just using them as marbles against
each other this is not something that
you do you don't just mess with this
level of power so the fact that you're
harnessing it and you're using it to
create artifacts arms and Armament right
using it to create this mysterium
element you don't fully understand what
you're dabbling with not only that he
says because of what you're doing here
you're going to start drawing the
attention of people right like you know
Doctor Doom says to the best of my
ability or to the best of my knowledge
one of the main principles of mysterium
is that it has anti-magical properties
you start messing around with the idea
of anti-magic you're going to start
drawing the wrong kind of attention
you're going to start drawing the
attention of people who want to see your
Empire and your ability to use mysterium
totally destroyed and that's when storm
basically gets a call in from Abby
Abigail brand who'd been contacted by by
Star-Lord and saying hey so like
basically dwar mom who's launching an
attack against the universe uh we're
probably gonna need your all's help in
some capacity and that's when Doom
chimes in and he's like I told you that
was gonna happen I told you you were
going to draw the wrong kind of
attention for something now it's kind of
ironic about this is despite the fact
that the X-Men are kind of the center
point of mysterium which even then is a
bit of a misnomer it's actually sore
that discovered mysterium and the
ability to tap into it but the the
reason why this is so interesting here
is because this is the last time we see
the X-Men
we're not going to see storm or any of
the X-Men in the rest of this story it
literally just becomes a Doctor Doom
Centric story after this and so what
takes place here is that with Dr Doom
traveling to meet with the rest of the
Guardians of the Galaxy the question
that they ask here is why would dormammu
launch an attack against the universe
and why is dormammu launching this
specific attack now again these
questions will be answered at the end of
the story so it really is an important
thing that you guys stick around but
what Dr Doom says is the particular
planets they're being attacked by uh by
dormammu it's being done for a purpose
right there's a reason why he's doing it
that the worlds that he's attacking
spart attacks holla so on and so forth
right that if you actually map them out
on a Celestial chart it forms a
pentagram that's literally what he's
doing that by attacking these different
worlds and then conquering and
subjugating these worlds he's forming a
pentagram on a universal scale which you
can use to enter into the universe now
this is one of those interesting moments
when Marvel kind of or at least a writer
introduces their own way for dormamu to
enter into the universe because he can
enter in through virtually any measure
right there's all kinds of ways dormammu
can show up here and so what they
realize here is that on this sort of
universal pentagram there's a planet
that's missing right there's a planet
that they simply haven't discovered yet
that if this planet is under attack by
dormammu and he's able to subjugate this
world it would lead to him entering into
the universe Dr Doom analyzing all of
this comes to the realization that is
the home planet of the chatari now the
funny thing about this and this is
what's so wild here is he says we have
to basically form two strike teams right
Rocket Raccoon has this idea which
honestly I as Doctor Doom find to be a
little bit goofy when he's like we're
basically going to take a giant gun and
we're going to shoot dormammu in the
head uh that's not really going to work
and Dr Doom's like I get that's what you
think of raccoon because you're kind of
stupid but I'm smarter than you are and
I'm smarter than everybody else so my
plan is really the better plan and so
his idea is we need to basically travel
to the chatari Homeworld find out how
far reaching his ability to to conquer
that world is and then hopefully Stave
off his ability to take over that world
and then in turn find some magical
process to defeat dormammu here's the
thing though a lot of their ability to
do these things are all tied up Doctor
Strange is dead right like he's gone
Stephen's strange he's out of the
picture that's what makes things so wild
and they they could invoke Cosmic
entities or something like that but for
whatever reason it makes sense to nobody
but the writer of the story they don't
so what this basically does is it leads
to them having to invoke magic in some
capacity and so he says if this Atari
are under attack we would never know
because they would never ask for help
they would never ask for Aid in any
capacity and so there is a bit of
distrust that goes on here because it is
Doctor Doom and so it's like I mean do
we trust this guy I mean it's Doctor
Doom right like I mean he's obviously
got some kind of scheme of his sleeve
there's something that he's probably
doing to either make this happen or is
going to use the situation to his own
Advantage but that's why everybody's
sort of split because one half of the
group is like I mean what choice do we
have right we're talking about magical
energy right we're the Guardians of the
Galaxy and miscellaneous other
superheroes We Fight Thanos right like
we beat up Thanos when Thanos is somehow
emerged and has some kind of campaign we
we Face Off against other alien races we
try to stop Galactus or the Silver
Surfer this is a whole different level
of power and it's one that we're not
readily familiar with and so in truth
they have to side with Dr Doom and so
where Richard Ryder is the odd man out
and he's like no I don't trust anything
that's that's going on here like I don't
trust anything with Dr Doom Gamora ends
up joining his son now a lot of that's
because Gamora and Richard Ryder have a
strong history together truth to tell
and I really hope we get this in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Richard Ryder
is one of the only people in Marvel
Comics to climb Mount Gamora and come
back for seconds you know what I mean
like one of the very few instances where
that ever happens and so it's kind of
like I mean it makes sense right they
have a very long history together they
were part of the select during the
Phalanx story and Annihilation Conquest
so again they've kind of been around the
block together a few times so it makes
sense that she would Ally with him
everybody else ends up going with Doctor
Doom and so what's really cool about
this is once they get to the planet of
the jatari Dr Doom comes with this
realization the whole thing's been
conquered and when they ask the question
how in the world could dormamu conquer
this place so easily that Dr Doom
actually points out this really really
cool thing that I never considered
before now when it comes to the chatari
they have a hierarchical structure
that's led by a matriarch and it's
actually being built on with the events
of secret Empire because if you guys
recall that story with Captain America
one of the things Captain America had
done when the Red Skull had changed his
history using a Cosmic Cube is Captain
America as the leader of Hydra had taken
the the shatari queen and brought her to
Earth and so the jatari were a lot we're
constantly launching an attack against
Earth as best they could in order to
find their Queen it was a really really
cool thing they'll go they'll literally
destroy themselves in order to defeat
whatever Force they're going against to
capture the queen and that that's why Dr
Doom says that was the target of dormamu
that literally the jitari only ever
exists in three forms that you've got
their Baseline drones who just follow
orders then you have the ones who
basically give those orders and then
you've got the queen who sends the
orders out to the ones who give the
orders and it's really just that simple
so all dormammu had to do was show up
here seize control of the queen and the
jittari race fell like that right it was
just that quick and so what Doctor Doom
does is that where they kind of ask the
question then how the heck are we
supposed to overpower these guys Dr Doom
actually reveals that the vessel that
they're on is not just a ship that
instead is actually a terraforming
platform and what they do or at least
what the ship does is it harvests the
material from around shatari's face and
then it starts producing Doom bots using
those which is amazing so literally
Doctor Doom has a ready-made vessel to
produce an army of doombots all of whom
just come descending down onto the
chatari and start annihilating pretty
much all of them now this is where
things get really cool because what
happens here is that with Richard Ryder
and Gamora traveling to Hala under the
idea that Hala is the least protected
planet of all those planets that are out
there right the most most susceptible to
an attack that in turn while he's
fighting alongside Wendell Von Quasar
and vital Vel and so on and so forth
that he actually asked Wendell Von like
hey so you talked to Galactus a lot
right and when I was like I mean yeah
before Galactus was destroyed by Thor
yeah like I talk to him all the time and
so he asked the question which by the
way the story where Thor destroys
Galactus that's down in the description
is every bit as awesome as you think it
is right it was just an amazing moment
in Marvel Comics Galactus has been dead
ever since I can't wait for the story
where he returns I have no idea what
story that's going to be but he
basically says so like ego is part of
the eternity watch right like basically
a gathering of cosmic entities that kind
of did what the Guardians of the Galaxy
did but they were just less involved
than the Guardians of the Galaxy were
and and window Von's like I mean yeah he
was for a little bit why do you ask and
he's like because when ego was part of
the eternity watch with Galactus
Galactus gave the ego the ability to
grow a body right and that's when
windows like yeah but I mean without
Galactus here ego the living planet's
not going to be able to grow a body in
any capacity but the reason why Richard
Ryder is asking this question is because
out in space an enormous portal has
formed and out of that portal comes the
full form of dormammu possessing the
body of ego The Living Planet now here's
one thing that I want to specify yes
this is dormammu using the power that
was given to Ego by Galactus to form a
physical body for himself this is not
the quote unquote True Form dormammu if
True Form dormammu entered into the main
Marvel Universe this fight would be over
like that right it'd be over in an
instant and so following this what it
does is it basically picks up with the
implementation of doctor Doom's plan
that what Doctor Doom reveals here is
that as part of this plan each of these
members of the Guardians of the Galaxy
were particularly assembled or at least
brought in by Dr Doom and the reason why
he was so huge on having them is because
based on the tarot cards these guys need
to be there now for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with this this is a
relatively new development not
necessarily in terms of Marvel Comics
but in terms of Dr Doom and how
frequently they're implemented so this
goes back to the old secret Defender
stories with Doctor Strange In the 1990s
and the idea behind that story or that
line of comics it was an amazing concept
that was terribly implemented but the
idea behind that concept is that doctor
strange would draw a series of tarot
cards based on whatever threat he was
facing off against and whoever was on
those tarot cards that's the team that
he would assemble so say for example and
we're just using arbitrary names because
I don't remember off top my head who was
involved in any one of those particular
stories it was 30 years ago right just
bear with me here but let's say that the
tarot cards were drawn and it was
Spider-Man Wolverine blade and like
Captain America that's the team that
doctor strange would assemble to face
off against like Mephisto or something
like that and so this is an instance
where Dr Doom is effectively doing the
same thing that according to the tarot
cards Drax the Destroyer moon dragon the
daughter of Drax Star-Lord Groot and
really was supposed to be Gamora that
they all had to be here in order to make
this work now of course Doctor Doom goes
as far as to say that with alcamora here
that's fine but each one of these
individuals in some capacity has some
sort of involvement with the cosmic
energies that exists out there is a
really good example moon dragon is a
universal telepath so she's a person
that can kind of tap into the
subconscious of everything in existence
and even the conscious minds of all
things in existence right she's the moon
Queen the Mistress of dragons the Tamer
of monsters so on and so forth but she
represents the idea that some kind of
wild beast which is sort of what
dormammu represents that He Could Be
Tamed right he could be controlled
basically harnessed and just kind of
have change thrown around him so to
speak but it's just kind of a general
General series of terms that I'm using
for like basically reigning in a beast
everybody else plays a role similar to
that but by having them stand in
particular locations and then casting a
spell what it does is it allows Doctor
Doom to effectively form a pentagram now
the reason why that that matters and why
that pentagram is significant is because
in doing so it's able to tap into the
power of dormammu and then force him to
falter right to siphon off a portion of
his energy now while it doesn't
completely take away dormammu's power
it's enough for him to kind of be like
what in the heck is that like I don't
understand what that is right that's
literally what's going on here is that
it's enough to kind of siphon his power
momentarily which weakens him and then
it allows like Rocket Raccoon and the
other forces of the Guardians of the
Galaxy to literally fire off a massive
gun and basically destroy the planet of
ego when it destroys the planet of ego
that removes the ability of dormammu to
possess it and that in turn allows Dr
Doom to finish the spell and then using
the power of everybody else Force
dormammu back into his own realm right
back into the dark dimension which
basically brings an end to a dormammu or
at least his campaign here now here's
where things get cool right here's where
things get really really interesting so
we didn't initially know why in the
world this was all done in the first
place right why would dormammu launch
into attack against the main Marvel
Universe it's out of character form to a
degree right when dormammu does
something like that one it's usually on
a grandiose stage and two it's usually
because in some involvement he'll res
he'll reference like Stephen Strange it
would be more in line with what dormammu
would do if he was like now that Stephen
Strange is dead I'm launching my attack
that's more like what door mama would do
here so the question is why would he
launch his attack how did he even get
here in the first place how did that
happen so what we end up doing is
actually picking up with a conversation
with Dr Doom and he says perhaps some
spark of sentience remains in the
floating Rubble perhaps not either way
it is over ego The Living Planet is
destroyed and he's no longer possessed
by dormammu and that's when Dr Doom says
it was a gamble true had the raccoon
scheme failed the dark lord might have
destroyed us all but Doom does not
gamble against the odds all went as
planned and that's when this person says
as we plan doom and he says as I planned
but you played your part to perfection
sister talianis now here's the thing
about sister talianes she is a
relatively new introduction in a Marvel
Comics I believe she's gonna become a
significant player in Marvel because she
is a person that actually stood against
the entirety of the cree and scroll
imperiums uniting but she's also someone
that can tap into magical power that
seemingly Dr Doom literally says my
involvement would have raised suspicion
but you could seduce ego into your Cult
of Vengeance opening the door for his
possession by dormamu and thus for
dormammu's own campaign of Conquest all
according to my design you did my work
well sister and so that's when when the
question now becomes okay so if Dr Doom
orchestrated the entire invasion of
dormammu into the main Marvel Universe
why and so what happens here is that
where sister Italiana says in the
meantime did you get all you wanted from
this game Lord Doom because this was all
done at least as far as sister taliana's
concern was so she could basically
conquer like jitarian and stuff like
that not a major focal point for a
character I think she will become
important later on but Doctor Doom
literally says I did not get everything
I wanted the mutants remained obdering
which I don't even know what the hell
that word means we'll just call it
obstinate right they refuse to cooperate
I assume that's what it means given the
context and he says though perhaps I
have planted the seed of doubt in them
and the sword of space remains with
hulkling but I have the magic of
dormammu far more of it than the
guardian's guest bound into my armor
until I choose to unlock it a potent
weapon which I will keep to myself until
the proper moment until the events of
Reckoning War that's literally why Dr
Doom did this Doctor Doom orchestrated
this entire situation so he could steal
a portion of dormammu's power because
truth to tell regardless of how powerful
dormammu is it's a Fool's errand if you
were to just go into the realm of the
dark dimension attack dormamus try to
steal some of his power and leave he
would face certain death either that or
dormammu would seize control of Doctor
Doom and then invade the main Marvel
Universe and imagine handling the power
of Doctor Doom along with his own power
in the main Marvel Universe I mean
that's a story I would read right like
dormammu possesses Doctor Doom and
attacks the main Marvel universe that
story would be dope I'm not even gonna
lie I would read the hell out of that
but that's the whole thing behind this
Dr Doom implemented this whole scheme
set this whole thing up just to steal a
portion of dormammu's power so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
Bruce